this is a production of Cornell
University
well thanks a lot Matt I really
appreciate hosting and I enjoyed having
breakfast with you and Christine and so
thanks I know it takes a lot of work to
you know host a person and I also want
to thank Bob and Kirsten in the soil
health lab who spent all morning with me
showing me all the different labs and so
I've been sending samples into soil
health lab since 2006 and it was neat to
see where they all go and so you know
thanks for taking that time in terms of
getting started here I wanted to give
you tell you a little story of just kind
of the background and some of the
motivations and inspirations that got me
and my colleagues into working with
cover crop mixtures so this is a field
day that I attended back in 2010 and I
wasn't really sure what I was getting
into when I went to this field day but
you know you can see the the excitement
the throngs of people just like what's
going on inside this tent when I arrived
it's like who's you know what are they
all here for it's a cover crop field day
and inside that tent was this guy yeah
this is Ray Archuleta with NRCS and he's
about to do a slake test right he's got
this soil sample here he's gonna drop it
in this jar how many of you ever seen
ray Archuleta do a slake test okay a
couple you've probably seen Bob do some
Bob Jindal back through some slate test
right so I forget exactly what he's
about to say but it might have been this
is the soil where we grew Ray's crazy
mix and this is the soil that was left
fallow and tilled and he's gonna drop
them in and you know the Ray's crazy mix
clod is gonna stay intact and the other
one's gonna dissolve and in a road away
and whatnot Rees crazy mix is a real
thing you can google it there's a winter
mix and a summer mix and so you know
then he'd go on to say these cover crop
mixtures they're gonna allow you to grow
crops without any fertilizer and you're
gonna be able to do no-till without any
herbicides and you're gonna be I'll sell
the sunflowers and make an extra 30
grand for a year at the farmers market
and they're gonna solve all your
problems and what's great is that it
it's getting the farmers enthusiastic
about it and it's getting them to plant
cover crops and you know I'm kind of
using Ray as a prop here he's you know
one of the people I think has done the
most to get farmers enthusiastic about
soil health and cover cropping so I
appreciate his work but what I think we
need to do and what we've tried to do
over the last ten years is let's get
from Ray's go from Ray's crazy mix where
it's just a bunch of things together and
and expect all these miracles that
happen let's go to Ray's smart mix or
Ray's precise mix where we know exactly
what we're doing why we're doing it were
assembling the right species were
planting it at the right time were we're
measuring and monitoring things so that
we know how to react in our next cash
crops and let's put the same amount of
thought and and thought and precision
into managing our cover crops that we
put into managing our cash crops so
that's kind of been the motivation that
and what I want to share today is some
work that a large team of people at Penn
State have contributed to over over the
last 10 years so you know this is a list
of students and farmers and faculty
members and postdocs and technicians
that have all worked on multiple
different grants to help improve our
understanding of cover crop management
and the multiple services that they
provide and and how we can be more
precise and so I'm going to share work
that all of these people have
contributed to I've I've worked in
partnership with them you know by no
means as any of this exclusively my work
as an extension specialist I get the
honor of kind of being the front person
for a lot of this work and going out and
telling people about it and so but I
just want to recognize all the people in
the background of this so one of our
first questions was about cover crop
multi-functionality
so the idea of mixing species together
that you could get more than you can get
from an individual species alone we
wanted to test that idea and figure out
what is it about mixtures how do you
assemble mixtures that could be more
multifunctional so there's
a lot of different services biomass
production nitrogen retention nitrogen
by cash crop productivity profitability
pest suppression weed suppression
improving soil carbon all of these
services we'd like to find a mixture
that performs well at all of these as
compared to individual monocultures and
so we designed an experiment at the
research station initially and also over
time kind of spreading out multiple
on-farm experiments and we had six
species of cover crops that we tested in
monoculture so we had two legumes red
red and ultimately we switched to
crimson clover later in the experiment
an Austrian winter pea we had two
brassicas canola and four radish and
then two grasses started with cereal rye
and triticale ultimately we moved to it
in the second half of the experiment
years 3 through 6 and then oats and so
these are different functional groups
I'm kind of family's plant families that
have different attributes the legumes
are nitrogen fixers the brassicas have
interesting tissue chemistry and broad
leaves you know the grasses are nitrogen
scavengers and have fibrous root systems
they're also kind of crossed here or
categorized into winter hardy and winter
killed species so different growth
growth periods and growth phonologies
and then so growing these in monoculture
we also wanted to compare them in
mixtures so we assembled kind of
strategically assembled some mixtures to
three species mixtures that three
species n retargeting nitrogen services
so nitrogen retention by including a
winter hardy grass the Rye and nitrogen
fixing with two legumes so we're trying
to balance these two nitrogen services
you know
achieve both of those functions the
three species W which is for weeds where
we wanted to focus on weed suppression
so we have a very fast-growing fall
grass the oat to you know create a
canopy quickly we have the ride to
continue suppressing into the spring but
because in this experiment were rotating
into
we didn't really want to have a huge
nitrogen penalty from lots of
immobilization so we threw in a clover
as well to broaden things out and then
we started adding more species so the
four species mix I'm is really similar
to the three species nitrogen except we
threw in canola and so canola is going
to be winter hardy it produces flowers
very early in the spring so maybe we
increase the service provisioning to
attracting beneficial insects or
resources for native pollinators also
you know interesting tissue chemistry
with canola having the glucosinolates
you know maybe that's gonna affect the
microbiome or you know do something for
weed suppressive nough something like
that and then finally all six species
together out of the more is better
insurance hypotheses maybe we have some
redundancies and functional traits in
here but also a highest species richness
so one of the ways to measure diversity
is just number pure number of species so
this would be the richest of the of the
mixtures odds planted on a 30-acre on
long term site so this square of plots
here is the 30 acres it's certified
organic it's in a three-year crop
rotation of winter wheat and then after
the winter wheat is harvested in in July
in August we plant the cover crop
treatment so the strip here where you
see the multiple plots of different
colors this picture is probably taken in
September and so you see our different
cover crop treatments down the length
here so that's all the monocultures plus
the mixtures and a fallow that cover
crop will then get terminated in the
spring and go into corn which I believe
this is our corn crop right here and
then after corn we just plant a
monoculture of cereal rye and then
rotate it into soybeans is the third
crop in the rotation then the soybeans
get planted into wheat so it's an annual
rotation organic management in this
experiment so when we looked at the
multi-functionality
score so if you take all of those
services and kind of stand
them to the mean value of that service
and then average those mean values
together we get a multi-functionality
average multi-functionality score if we
just want to think about richness so if
a farmer wants to get
multi-functionality and they just think
okay should I have three species four
species six species you know is
increasing the species number is that
what's gonna take to increase
multi-functionality what we saw is a
very very weak relationship to average
multi-functionality
some of our monocultures like the pea
were even more multifunctional than any
of the mixtures we've seve got some
variability around the line here but in
general you know three three versus four
versus six not that different in terms
of their multi-functionality so it
seemed like just increasing species
number is not necessarily the key that
farmers should should use as as their
strategy for assembling a
multifunctional cover crop we looked at
a number of other metrics diversity
metrics and we started getting into the
functional diversity metrics and I'm
gonna talk a little bit about functional
diversity in a second here but the one
functional diversity metric that was on
the best predictor of
multi-functionality is this term called
rouse quadratic entropy how many of you
have heard of or no rouse quadratic
entropy anyone okay I'm not surprised
very very few people are as into the
weeds to know what this is and it's
certainly not listed on a cover crop bag
of seed right you know you're not gonna
get the percent rouse quadratic entropy
you know you might get the amount of
weed seeds in there but you're not gonna
get the you know tested by the
Department of Agriculture you're not
gonna get browsed podriatic entropy so
what is what is r as quadratic entropy
what is functional diversity in general
so you need to understand functional
diversity before you can understand how
to make a cover crop multifunctional so
functional diversity has to do with not
so the number of species but what the
functional traits of the species are and
when we talk about functional trait this
is kind of a like a physiological trade
or or of a species and so things like
fall growth rates so how many pounds per
acre per growing degree day will a
species be able to put on under optimal
growing conditions and these functional
traits are related to the services of
interest so for example fall growth rate
should theoretically assist with weed
suppression being able to retain
nitrogen being able to produce biomass
of of that cover crop spring growth rate
should help with nitrogen retention
carbon inputs the c2n ratio should be
able to help with nitrogen supply the
list of functional traits could go on
and on and on and on you know route
length density leaf area index flower
density there's endless list of
functional traits we selected these
because there are things that a granola
Klee are easy to interpret and easy to
measure but you know the list could
really be expanded and I think some of
the future of multi-functionality and
cover crops is what are the additional
functional traits that we could measure
and use to predict different services so
that's what functional traits are but
then to understand what functional
diversity is you have to think about
these multiple different traits and how
they arrange themselves in what we call
the trait space and so this is with
three traits it's nice and easy to be
able to you know plot things on a three
dimensional axis and you know visualize
this in space but mathematically
speaking you know we have we can do the
math on you know more than three
dimensions five dimensions ten
dimensions twelve dimensions of trait
space the math all all works for it but
essentially you know thinking about an
individual species where it falls in the
trait space so for example red clover
has a relatively low fall growth rate on
a medium spring growth rate and a very
low C to end ratio rye has medium
all growth rate but very high spring
growth rate and a high seed ratio so
that's where it falls in this three
dimensional trait space here so then
when you start assembling mixtures you
can see where did the different species
in each mix fall in this three
dimensional trait space so here's our
three species n that's got the rye the P
and the red clover so that's what the
functional trait space of this mixture
looks like for the three species weeds
you know again kind of a triangular
plane there of trade space we add the
four species here we've got canola in
the middle the sooner so I've kind of
created this convex hull around them
with the with the lines here and then
our six species mix is here so this is
each of the mix each of the mixes in the
trait space the next thing with
functional diversity is understanding
components of the functional diversity
so you can have components of diversity
whether it's based on functions are
based on just species numbers there is
evenness richness and divergence and an
evenness in functional diversity even
this would be a perfectly even mixture
would have the same amount of biomass of
each of the species in the mix right
third of the biomass with this third a
third or quarter quarter quarter or one
six one six one six that would be a
perfectly even mix the more you have
biomass concentrated on one species
versus the others the less even you get
right so that's kind of you know pretty
simple one to think about richness if
we're thinking about kind of species
number richness just means increasing
number of species but when we're talking
about functional diversity what richness
is is an increasing volume in the
functional trait space so if you were to
draw this convex hull around the species
in the trade space the bigger that
volume is the richer your functional
diversity is so here if we go from say
the three species end to add in canola
we've kind of taken a three dimensional
plane and we've added another
so now we've got out of a pyramid so
we've increased the volume here we've
got more species that are increasing the
volume the size of that hole that's a
more that's a richer functionally richer
mixture and then the last thing we can
look at in terms of the diversity
component is divergence and divergence
means how far apart from the middle are
your species spread and so these would
be very divergent the three species
mixes here are very divergent because
all of the species are at the edges of
the trait space when we go from the
three species n2 add in canola which is
kind of in the middle of the trait space
we actually reduce the divergence
because we're bringing weight or
emphasis into the middle of the
functional trait space rather than
keeping it at the edges of the trait
space so there's lots of different
metrics that you can calculate metrics
like relative Rao's quadratic entropy
that will kind of weight on evenness or
weight on richness or weight on
divergence or kind of combined evenness
and richness together or look at all
three and relative Rao is a metric that
essentially measures the evenness and
the divergence of the functional trait
space and so what that's telling us the
fact that relative Rao of all of the
possible metrics we could look at
relative Rao being predictive and this
is the second paper where we found
relative Rao was most predictive so two
different data sets so it's you know a
little bit robust in that regard it's
the evenness in the divergence and so
what that tells us is we want to have
even species composition and we want to
have species that are on the edges of
the trait space so for example putting
some emphasis on canola which is in the
middle of the trait space that's
actually going to reduce our our our
divergence what's interesting is
richness didn't really matter so it
doesn't matter how far out or how big
your volume is as long as you've got you
know some strength around the edges and
it's evenly distributed that seems to
make for
a more multifunctional mixture so I
think this helps us understand better
what the functional aspects are and how
we can manage for them now the other
thing I want to say is that the
functional traits that you throw into
that this analysis could be an eye of
the beholder right
we don't have flower flower density on
here canola has huge flower densities
that was one of our functional traits
that we were interested in for bringing
in pollinators
you know canola wouldn't be in the
middle anymore it would be way out here
it would now be on the edge so it's
really a little bit subjective about
what your goals are so I think there's
an opportunity for farmers to be able to
say okay I want to have one have flowers
I want to have a dense root system to
build a great stability so maybe route
length density would be one of my
functional traits not that concern about
nitrogen supply maybe I've got a lot of
manure to utilize so maybe I'm not gonna
first see the end ratio in as one of my
one of my traits of interest so I think
this is also a framework that's
adaptable and can help farmers you know
hone in on what's important to them and
then have a quantitative framework to
help assess okay these are the ones that
are gonna be my divergence species in
this trade space and then we're gonna
try and manage them for evenness so one
of the challenges though is that is the
evenness aspect and in the first round
of our experiments we had a lot of
challenge developing even species
distributions over time so this chart
shows kind of over the progression of
the cover crop from seeding to
germination to fall biomass to spring
biomass what is the proportion allocated
to each of the species and you can see
over time this green bar here which is
the cereal rye tended to dominate things
in this in the spring and so that's a
challenge because that's going to
disrupt the evenness of the the mixture
there so this is a picture of the cereal
rye and the spring cereal rye is just
those who've worked with it know it's
very fast growing in the spring it got
way out ahead of all of our you know
peas and and red clover and it was very
uneven
other settings the canola became became
dominant so this is one of our on-farm
locations in a warmer part of the state
four species mix just turned into all
canola right so these are some
challenges that you know you have the
best intentions you make this nice seed
blend and then the environment kind of
swamps everything so how do we look at
what the environmental context is and
and adjust and work around that I'm just
some examples here of our our four
species mix that we put out across four
different on-farm locations and our
research station and behave very
differently depending on the context the
yellow part of the pie being the
proportion of biomass that's in canola
so you know responds respond Ola really
responds like crazy so you know we have
this question of how do these cover crop
mixtures respond to environmental
conditions over over different space
which might be different climate regions
or fertility levels in the soil we had a
hypothesis that the planting date and
the nitrogen rate would potentially
control mixture expression and so we set
up an experiment at our research station
which this is a picture of it here where
we experimentally manipulated the
planting dates in the fall and
experimentally manipulated nitrogen
additions and then we also just deployed
satellite experiments on different farms
around Pennsylvania and we actually had
a couple sites in New York to mrs.
Torres farm up here so not too far from
here and we grew the cover crops we
compiled all the data and we wanted to
analyze it and say okay let's look at
our hypothesis of nitrogen supply and
climate in the fall in terms of growing
degree days how does that affect the
composition of this mixture and so we
used a path analysis to look at look at
it so kind of our independent variables
here are inorganic soil and a planting
this is milligrams per kilogram of
nitrate and ammonium at planting and
then the growing degree days between
planting and December 31st and you can
manipulate that either through your
climate you can get a colder region that
just has your growing degree days or you
can manipulate that through planting
dates so if you plant three weeks
earlier
you're gonna accumulate that many more
growing degree days in in the fall and
so what we saw is that growing degree
days increasing growing degree days
increased growth of all of our species
this is fall cover crop biomass and and
the only species that really responded
to the inorganic soil end of planting
was canola and then these coefficients
essentially give you an idea for every
unit change in inorganic soil and what's
going to be the change in canola biomass
kilograms per hectare so one part per
million of inorganic end is going to
create an additional forty four
kilograms per hectare of canola and one
growing degree day is going to create
2.8 kilograms per hectare of canola and
one of the things that we see is that
canola is much more responsive than the
other species so none of the other
species responded to inorganic N and
canola responded five times as much as
the next species actually six times as
much seven times as much as the next one
triticale in terms of growing degree
days so an extra growing degree day for
canola is much more impactful than for
triticale
so canola is extremely responsive and
then these negative coefficients are
kind of interspecific competition so the
canola an increased kilogram per hectare
of canola decreased the growth of all of
the other species so in this way canola
is kind of acting like a little bit of a
keystone species in terms of having
these effects on on the on the community
this is what the data looks like just at
the research station in terms of our
different planting dates and our
nitrogen additions you can see as the
planting dates got earlier we had more
growing degree days the yellow bars for
canola get bigger and bigger and within
each planting date adding nitrogen
stimulated the canola and just a visual
assessment on the first planting date
this is what the mixture looked like
with canola dominating when we added
nitrogen when we didn't add
eugen there's much more legumes and
triticale that are able to persist in
the next so these are things that you
know farmers can choose their planting
data in the fall if they're coming after
a wheat or a small grain they've got a
very wide window where they can plant
you know they could choose a plant in
early August or they could choose to
plant in mid September and it seems like
if you want to get a more even
composition than planting a little bit
later is important you could also choose
whether or not you're gonna add
fertility Ziff you've got manure on your
farm say you know what if I've got
canola in a mix am I gonna put manure
out probably it's not a good idea
because you're just gonna disrupt the
composition of that mix make it very
uneven so I think there's some
management factors that can be used the
other thing would be you know you really
need canola in the mix right so maybe
canola is a destabilizing force in in
the composition it's so reactive and
it's so competitive that maybe things
would be more even and stable without
that species so I think for resilience
of cover crops you know it's interesting
could be an interesting research line to
think about how resilient are different
cover crop mixtures species to different
environmental factors and things like
that one of the other things we saw with
planting date is on the we deenis - so
if you're trying to use cover crops to
manage weeds in the fall or manage the
weed seed bank seems like the earlier we
plant our cover crops in the fall the
weedy or they get so this isn't a random
forest analysis actually very large data
set thousands of plots from lots of
different experiments where we measured
the cover crop biomass as well as the
weed biomass in the fall and you know as
you increase the fall grown degree days
here the weed biomass - this response
variable here is weed biomass really
starts to tick up here's some examples
from the planting date experiment where
we had triticale planted in early August
you see how infested with weeds it is
versus triticale planted in early
September and yeah there's some things
that germinated there but you know it's
cool enough that you know those are you
know not really going to get out of
control they're not going to set nearly
as many seeds so this could be a weed
weed
management strategy here too in terms of
of the planting date so what I want to
move into now is work that kind of my
lab group has really focused on over the
years looking at how we can better
assess the nitrogen contribution of
cover crops as well as soil organic
matter to the fertility of our following
cash crop we've looked at we've really
looked at corn as the model system here
because corn is it's one of the
predominant crops on the landscape it's
you know very responsive to nitrogen -
to maintain yields and so the way we
wanted to start looking at this work is
to start at thinking about the
fundamental theory and the fundamental
processes of nitrogen mineralization and
use that as a guiding principle in terms
of how we interpret and analyze the data
and be able to predict a response so
it's a fairly simple conceptual model of
how nitrogen mineralization occurs in
the soil you've got a decomposing
organic material with carbon and
nitrogen microbes decompose that
material they might use 25 to 50 percent
of that carbon to build their biomass
that we call that the carbon use
efficiency the remaining fraction is
respired into the atmosphere as co2 the
quantity of carbon that microbes
assimilate they need to assimilate a
similar or a proportional quantity of
nitrogen to build their biomass the
proteins and amino acids and whatnot
that they need that seed n ratio is
often about 10 to 1 but it might vary if
it's you know bacteria or fungi or
protozoa
but ten to one is kind of an average
value that a lot of people use for the
whole microbial community and what of
the nitrogen that decomposes from this
material but the microbes don't take up
into their biomass is what's available
to be mineralized into the soil for the
crop and of course those of you that
know this process well know that you
could not have enough nitrogen in the
decomposing material to feed to meet the
microbial biomass demand and then you
immobilize nitrogen so you could
actually tie up nitrogen as the microbes
build their biomass so the cover crop
seed to end ratio is an important
control
this so that's the theory and the very
nice thing about this theory is that's
pretty easy to turn it into an equation
so this is the classic biogeochemical
equation for nitrogen mineralization
I've got the seed and ratio of the cover
crops the seed n ratio of the microbes
the carbon use efficiency you've got the
end content of the decomposing material
here you've got a coefficient for the
decomposition rate and that's nitrogen
mineralization so we wanted to use this
equation in this theory to say okay
we've got a cover crop residue that we
can measure the nitrogen content we can
measure the C to end ratio we've got
soil organic matter that we can measure
you can measure carbon and maybe it's
got a fairly stable C to end ratio as
pools that go through this process of
decomposition let's see if we can use
this as an equation to predict nitrogen
supply to the corn crop and so what we
did is is we distilled a set of
equations from the theory that could be
calibrated to predict essentially the
corn yield response so we didn't look at
soil mineral nitrogen which is what a
lot of people do we said we want to take
this right to yield you want to see how
this mineralization process affects the
yield of the corn so that's our response
variable is the yield of an unfertilized
corn crop we have a parameter for the
carbon use efficiency or actually I call
it the human efficiency and human is a
little bit different than carbon use
efficiency carbon use efficiency is for
one generation of microbes but you've
got a three or four month growing season
where you might have multiple
generations of microbes and so you need
to account for okay the bacteria are
going to get ate by eaten by protozoa
and then those protozoa ZAR gonna die
and so your carbon use efficiency might
be might be your your overall efficiency
which i call the human efficiency might
be lower on that human efficiency
there's also a lot of theory to suggest
that that's affected by the soil texture
so finer textured soils more clay
content can stabilize carbon stabilized
dead microbial biomass protected against
the K by that work has come out of
Cornell so appreciative to those who
have worked on that I've read read a lot
of those papers and and gained a lot
from that
so our efficiency factor we said
theoretically okay we're gonna allow
that to vary based on the soil texture
we've got a credit here for the yield
response to soil organic matter and
that's gonna be again affected by the
human efficiency there's a few things
that simplify out of this equation we
assume that the c2n ratio of microbial
biomass and the CDN ratio of soil
organic matter are going to be similar
ten ten ten to one so those actually
cancel out with each other we just get
one minus E and then these coefficients
that you see in here are coefficients
that are calibrated to our data set so
it's I'm not doing any hand waving here
it's just the data is telling us what
these should be we've got a yield credit
for cover crop residues decomposing so
this is our you know kind of full
formalized equation here we've got the
end content of the cover crops the humic
a tional fishin see the seed end ratio
of the cover crops and then alpha is a
parameter here which composites both the
decomposition rate as well as the
efficiency of that mineralized nitrogen
in converting into corn yield okay so
are you our response variables always
the yield so there's this kind of takes
into some nitrogen use efficiency as
well
and we found that that parameter
depended on whether the cover crop was
going to mineralize nitrogen or
immobilise and when it immobilizes this
value becomes negative and actually the
effect of an immobilizing cover crop is
much more strong than the effect of a
mineralizing cover crop and that's
that's interesting because that nitrogen
mineralization some of that mineralized
nitrogen might get lost
I get D nitrified it might get leached
and so that's kind of an interesting
finding and then the last thing we said
is okay we've got this credit from the
organic matter credit from the cover
crop let's add these together and we
know that corn yield kind of has a
diminishing return to increased nitrogen
supply and so let's throw a quadratic
term in here to represent that
diminishing supply so this was our
system of equations and we threw a
dataset at it from 125 different plots
that will run different sites with
different textures different soil
organic matter levels different
crop residues different nitrogen levels
and we said let's see if we can
calibrate these terms and we were able
to do that and we got a pretty good
r-squared
we had a wide range of unfertilized
yield potential across all of all of
these different sites so I think it's a
big advance in terms of being able to
very precisely and with very strong
biogeochemical theory behind it be able
to predict the nitrogen content of
nitrogen contribution of soil organic
matter and cover crops to to the yield
of corn so now that we've got this out
of the way the next step is figuring out
what the how do you take that to a
nitrogen fertilizer requirement and
that's kind of a giant leap in and of
itself and we're in the process of
making that leap right now but the
approach we're taking is if you can
predict what the yield of your crop
would be without fertilizer and you know
from history what you've been able to
achieve through abundant or possibly
over abundant nitrogen applications
you've kind of got a yield Bowl in mind
for your particular climate and soil and
management system and so that the
difference between your yield goal and
what you can get without fertilizer
we're calling that the yield gap and
that yield gap to produce a bushel of
corn physiologically the plant needs to
take up about 1.2 pounds of nitrogen to
produce a bushel of corn based on the
stoichiometric ratios of of carbon and
nitrogen in a corn crop but we know that
that nitrogen isn't always delivered
with 100% efficiency so you've gotta
just buy some efficiency factor and a
lot of our research now is kind of
trying to figure out how do we test what
this efficiency factor is and how do we
predict that or adjust for that and so
you know in the future we're going to
have you know some results to be able to
share on that but for now I'm gonna kind
of leave the story of developing these
algorithms here the next step though is
to kind of create some user interfaces
like that's a nasty system of equations
they have to have a farmer sit down and
I have created a worksheet you know it's
just multiplication division in addition
you can do it but it's
you know some people look at you funny
when you ask them to fill out all that
things it's like you're doing taxes or
something so we put it in a web
interface to do all the equations and it
the interface predicts your unfertilized
yield and you can plug in your yield
goal and there's a yield gap there and
we're right now kind of making some
assumptions about what the fertilizer
efficiency is but we're trying to
fine-tune that and so this is a tool
that kind of field testing with some
select group of growers just you know
get their reactions and and see you know
how accurate it is and make do some
fine-tuning one of the other advances
that we've done to try and make this
more practical and and easier for
farmers to do is instead of taking your
cover crop biomass and getting going out
there with a quadrat and down and
clipping it and drawing in sending it
through the lab you know much nicer if
you could just walk a sensor over that
field and get the nitrogen content so
there's an N DVI sensor here made by
green seeker that's a hand-held sensor
that is five hundred dollars and you can
walk that across a cover crop plot and
I've just kind of on a hunch I got one
of those back when it was first released
maybe 2012 and every single cover crop
experiment we did I said all right
walked us across the cover crop plot and
we were able to develop a really nice
relationship between the NDVI value on
the sensor and the above-ground biomass
end content and I think it's accurate
enough and we've done some sensitivity
analyses in our equations that I think
even with some error it doesn't really
change the outcome too much and so I
think this is going to be a nice tool
going forward that you know if you need
to need that nitrogen content to run
some of these predictions you can get
that with a sensor you can also get a
model of this green seeker sensor that
you can map a field so you could put it
on a spray boonie if you're a toolbar of
a tillage implement so if you're going
across that field you can get the NDVI
value and make a map adjust spatially so
one of our projects that we've been
doing the last two summers has been to
look at infield variability of the cover
crop nitrogen content so that's
green seeker sensors here on a little
boom here on our buggy and we drive this
across the field and in swathes we're
pulling behind it a sensor that maps the
electrical conductivity of the soil the
surrogate for soil moisture let's assume
that soil moisture soil texture so you
know that texture component we can find
different zones in the field and you
know create prescriptions for that this
is an example of one of the cover crop
fields that we mapped this spring you
see there's a really wide range from 15
pounds of n to 135 pounds of dead in the
same field so being able to account for
some of that variability you could
adjust what the nitrogen credit is it's
a picture of this field and us driving
the buggy through it I also think
there's potential to view satellite
imagery so most of the agronomist I work
with now or either you don't have
subscriptions either in circa through
granular or climate a field view to get
daily satellite imagery of all their
fields as long as there's a cloud cover
to their smartphones and this satellite
imagery map looks a heck of a lot like
this NDVI map be nice if you could just
get that for all your fields right to
your phone or download it into your work
flow and and create some prescriptions
using that map of the soil electrical
conductivity zones for this field can
then go out and soil sample by zone and
a lot of farmers have already invested
in these EC maps and have developed you
know management zones or soil sampling
zones so they're already doing this and
so let's just get the soil texture and
the organic matter from those zones and
we can layer that in a corneal potential
by zone this is you know historical
records from this farmer and he's he's
pretty savvy he's done all the work
himself to create these yield zones that
he already uses to manage his P&K
applications to account for varying
levels of crop removal and then we put
all that together we run the you know
equations I showed you by zone and we
get a nice map of maybe what the
nitrogen fertilizer recommendation
should be by zone so this is still all
very experimental there's kinks that we
need to work out that efficiency factor
I showed you for the nitrogen that's a
big unknown that we're trying to hone in
on still but
kind of a proof of concept that you can
layer these things together and maybe be
more precise about how you credit the
nitrogen from from cover crops so you
know it's been 10 years since you know I
went to this field day it you know
inspired our group at Penn State to
really look into this this is what a
field day for hemp production looks like
now kind of past the peak for cover crop
mixtures I think we've learned a lot
farmers are kind of over the adoption
curve they're doing it now time to get
smart about it and precise about it
you know that cover crops can provide a
lot of benefits but you know they need
management you know they need
intentionality
so think about functional diversity and
you know the evenness and the divergence
as guiding principles adaptively
managing cover crops to promote evenness
so avoiding suppressive species like
canola minimizing residual nitrogen not
planting too early and then you know
some decision support tools for managing
cover crop nitrogen is something that
we've learned to work a lot on and in my
group and and are trying to move forward
so I'll leave it at that hopefully
there's a few minutes for some questions
and discussion so thank you the opposite
direction for that work should be using
our mint and then maybe beyond that if
you looked at other goals for the farmer
like beets depression and how that can
be put into a decision tool that sort of
integrates what different goals in
different climatic yeah so I'll just
repeat this in case people online so the
question is in terms of dishes and
support on the nitrogen side but we
looked at the reverse of saying let's
run some scenarios and figure out what
the right cover crop is in order to get
a certain amount of nitrogen and then
also for like weed management or other
services are there decision support
tools on the nitrogen side we definitely
can do what you're describing we haven't
advanced enough to work with grow
to use it in a proactive way but the
decision support tool I showed you
allows you to run scenarios so let's say
the dial in your organic matter dial in
your soil texture dial in your yield
goal and then you can adjust the amount
of cover crop nitrogen you can adjust
the c2n ratio and see what that does
here unfertilized yield and say okay you
know what we're really close to our our
yield goal here without any additional
fertilizer we don't need a massive Legum
cover crop maybe we could go with the
mixture or a cereal I'm something like
that or if we're really far away from
our yield goal we're gonna need a big
massive leg you monoculture here let's
let's focus on that so yeah it
definitely can be used that way on the
other side in terms of other additional
services I think it would be great I
think with a quantitative framework of
kind of functional diversity I think
there's an opportunity for someone to
create that it's a little bit beyond the
scope of what were what I'm looking at
my group now but I think you know maybe
others maybe the cover crop Council I
think the cover crop council is working
on something like that that we'll be
able to you know allow growers to check
off some functions that they want and
then help design a mix there yes sir
on those predictions that you're making
of nitrogen those equations I didn't see
in mention of like soil temperature so
moisture or maybe flooding yeah so the
question was there was about the
nitrogen equations there's no mention of
soil temperature or soil moisture so
flooding and right now we do not
specifically take those into account on
a site by site basis but through the
calibration process all of these sites
were calibrated in Penn Central to
Southeast Pennsylvania which has you
know kind of an average moisture regime
average temperature regime it's all
calibrated to the average conditions and
these were done over four or five years
so it's calibrated to the average
conditions of Pennsylvania and that
coefficient absorbs some of that
information now it's not going to be
able to tell you the difference between
a year that's hot and dry or a year
that's cold and wet or a year that we
have lots of denitrification and i think
it's this could be used as a
complementary tool to some of the models
like adapt end where you are taking into
account those very specific year by year
factors but of course there's you know
cost to adapt then in terms of the or
other models like that terms of the
computer infrastructure and requires
subscription services and things like
that what I really wanted was a tool
that was calibrated to the average
condition that you actually could do on
a piece of paper and I think that's a
really powerful thing and with some very
simple inputs and that was kind of my
goal so doesn't take into account
everything but I think it works well for
the average and the other thing is that
if people want to use these equations in
New York or Maryland I'm like good luck
because these are calibrated for
Pennsylvania and you know we've talked
with some people about ok let's get a
calibration for Wisconsin or let's get a
calibration for Maryland I think you
could do that you could do these
calibration studies they're not that
hard people probably already have the
data actually from existing experiments
and I think those coefficients are going
to change based on the temperature and
moisture regimes yes
thanks very much I have two questions
one is alright have you looked at canola
as a crop at all and the second question
is kind of your functional space you
know trying to make that bigger if you
have all winners a one winner that does
all three things perfectly but that
would be one die but it might be the
best so I'm a little confused about a
function sort of a bigger space is
basically saying I want to have like
fail your on multiple dimensions yeah
yeah so that's it that's a great
question and those are great great
points so one of the things we saw if
you remember the species richness
multi-functionality response the
monoculture P was actually the best
multifunctional performant I think
that's speaking to what you're saying a
single species that can do multiple
things well turned out to actually be
the best of the of the multiply
functionals in terms of functional
diversity the man
math falls apart when you only have one
one species right because you've got a
single single point you're gonna have
six that are all winners and you'll have
that same single point yes I think so
I'd have to think through that I'm not
able to fully think through it on my
feet here but I think that's that's
possible and and I think so what our
data was showing is that yeah you could
you don't always need a mixture to be
the most multi functional or to achieve
multi functionality you can sometimes
get that with the monoculture terms of
canola is an actual crop one of the
long-term experiments on our research
station that was just to the side of our
cover crop mixtures experiment has used
canola as a crop and I'm they're
actually harvesting as an oilseed and
they press the oil and they use that oil
to run the tractors and then they use
the meals as a dairy supplement in the
ration and it's interesting in in theory
there are a few farmers that are growing
canola in Pennsylvania they're kind of
growing room for the human food market
it's very specialty niche crop it was a
devil of a crop to grow it's hard to get
established gets eaten by slugs
there's tons of harvest losses with the
combine so not saying it can't be done
but it takes someone who really wants to
grow canola to be able to do it it's not
something that we're seeing average
farmers really jumping it adopting yep
it was okay straight to me that maybe
there is no average here ever the
prediction of nitrogen delivery
robustness maybe lies in coping with a
range of environmental conditions a dry
a wet here and everything
so by looking at average performance
both for the nitrogen delivery as well
as multi-functionality have you thought
about how can you move this in a
different way that actually it will bust
this - too erratic conditions which is I
think whether sustainability comes in
not the average yeah I think that's a
great point and I think we have had some
students that have started off looking
or you know started to look at that in
terms of you know performance over
different years and the resilience of
the systems and I'm not super familiar
with their work I'm not their adviser
and so I think people are are thinking
about that and I think that's a really
important point because yeah I do agree
that the average doesn't seem to exist
anymore it's just you know a lot of
variation around the average in any
given year
so but I do still think that yes so
finding things that are robust and
resilient I think is is important and I
think some of the work we're starting to
do with our nitrogen tool is to kind of
look at the sensitivity of it so how
sensitive is it's the different
parameters and is there is there some
level of stability that maybe we could
look towards so I think those are really
important points it's it's a well taking
yeah yeah yep okay well thank you
appreciate the opportunity this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu